what is this that's the worst advice
I've ever heard no no I don't want to
learn more let's debate this live on my
channel just because you haven't got a
billion pounds in your bank doesn't mean
you're not a billion your advice is
complete and utter nonsense what the
hell is this dude talking about and he
looks like a cartoon character my friend
has just sent me a bunch of apparently
really cheesy millionaire Tik Tok advice
type stuff so I'm going to watch them
I've got a feeling that that I might
actually agree with them and I might be
like yeah but he thinks they're cheesy
so let me watch them let me react to
them we'll see what happens I just
bought a house and I'm going to add my
kids' names to it so when I die they'll
inherit it don't do that why not if your
house goes up in value your kids will
pay the tax on the appreciation put it
in a living trust a living trust it
eliminates having to go to court
transferring the property to your kids
and most of all it's taxfree on the
appreciation what is this right like
16-year-old kids Googling trust oh wow
I'm so smart my friend okay you have no
idea what you are talking about for a
start you can't just move a property or
just put it in a living trust you do
realize my friend that to just just put
it in a living trust is to set up a
trust which is a big process where you
going to need experts to assist you and
to help you we're going to go what's the
reason for the trust I just save a few
th000 in capsul games tax what what for
serious people right so s trust cost
thousands of pound then to just put it
in a trust means selling it to a trust
which now means you're going to pay
stamp Duty tax again on the property
right you do realize your advice is
complete and utter nonsense you do
realize that the amount of money that
you would save on one single property
going from 300 to 500,000 you have spent
moreon in consultancy fees and setting
up the trust and stamp Duty tax you do
realize that if you pass down a trust to
your children yes you'll pay no
inheritance tax but they're not
inheriting the property inheriting the
trust and if they then sell the trust to
get the property then they have to pay
tax you know what you're talking about
yes there's a place for trusts I have a
trust right I have millions and millions
of pounds in a trust I get it I
understand it I just can we ban people
doing Tik Tok videos when they haven't
got experience of the thing they're
doing the Tik Tok video on please jeez
next video there is no reason for you to
be broke in the United States starting
pay at a fast food restaurant is $10 per
hour if you work to full-time jobs for
an entire year you should be able to
save at least $20,000 net after expenses
you do this for two years put that money
into a quadplex or a Triplex a
multi-unit building pay 3.5% down
payment rent out the other rooms in Just
2 years you can start cash flowing
several thousand a month net all from
working at a fast food place I agree
with him to a point and I strongly
disagree with him in another point I
like his attitude I like his energy I
like the fact that he's saying that
there's no excuse to be broke however
what he's doing is he's falling down the
Trap of work hard so he's saying you
know go and work in a job for $10 an
hour you know for 80 hours a week for a
year and save all that money but reality
is that doesn't work I think that the
average job is so low paid now how can
you live on the on the money also often
when you work hard and your money goes
up a little bit it's so easy to then
your expenses go up a little bit and you
end up after a year or two thinking I
thought I'd be able to save 20 grand but
actually I'll save four and now you're
in the race and you're used to and
accustomed to just working 80 hours a
week what would be much better to buy
that first property rather than working
your ass off and saving up 20 grand just
find a really good deal find an investor
to put the money in and give him half
the money I'd rather have 50% of
something than 100% of nothing do that
two three four times and the amount of
extra hours you'd be putting into
McDonald's I'd be putting into going
networking and and working smart but the
kids got good energy and he's got a good
point like this $100,000 watch without
spending a single dollar of your own
money using business credit like this
that you never actually have to pay back
let's say for example you will get a car
or a credit card in your personal name
you're personally held responsible for
that with business credit you are not
personally held responsible for that
line of credit so let's say for example
how I got this watch I was able to open
a business that I didn't really give a
about I went open business credit
cards in that account I then proceeded
to go on buy this $400,000 I'm going to
turn around and sell it to a jeweler for
$80,000 in cash which now gives me the
cash I'll file bankruptcy on the company
I'll never have to actually pay it back
that is absolute I take it back that's
the worst advice I've ever heard that is
absolute nonsense do you really think
that people that give out £100,000 loans
to businesses would be so stupid that if
some kid like that set up a company that
he in his own words don't give a
about that they'd be like oh yeah it's
coming 100 Grand of course they wouldn't
is the most ridiculous adice
does anyone actually listen to this and
and go wow I'm going to do that I'm
going to set up a company and then apply
for a loan cuz if you did all that would
happen is you'd waste your £12 setting
up a company which is how much it costs
in the UK to set up a company because no
one would give you loan anyway and even
if they would that would be the fastest
way to kill all credibility that you've
got anyway but now just go in horrible
horrible advice I don't this kid is
don't follow him stop watching people
like that let me show you how not to buy
a car you don't want to pay cash for a
car you definitely don't want to rent
your car and lease it and taking out a
loan from somebody else's bank you don't
want to do that either if we crying out
loud don't steal the car so the answer
is you're going to be your own bank
you're going to treat your money the
same as you treat the bank's money now
all you have to do is change one thing
and that one thing is where your money
goes first don't put it in someone
else's bank put it in your bank and once
we put it in your bank what we're going
to do is we're going to take loans from
your bank and we're going to buy the car
and instead of just saying okay I own
the car now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the same amount you
would have paid to the bank every month
and we're going to do something
different what take that 963 that you
would have paid to somebody else's bank
and we're going to pay that money back
into your private bank what are you
talking about part is in doing this you
earn uninterrupted compound interest on
every comp every dollar that you paid
for the car this is how you get back all
the money for every car you buy drive
and own just like my shows you no no no
I don't want to learn more I want to
just lease the car I'm going to become
my own bank I'm not going to instead of
putting the cash in there thing put it
in my bank what listen Mr car dude let's
debate this live on my channel and
either you're going to look like a
complete or I am which I'm happy
to and then I'll change my entire setup
and I won't lease or buy my cars I'll do
that weird circle thing that you do
which doesn't make any sense even if
that is correct you are the worst
communicator on God's Planet cuz I made
zero sense to me I'm a very smart
intellectual Finance dude that made no
sense to me let me tell you why you're
broke if you play Fantasy
Football quit if you walk a dog
especially your girlfriend's dog through
the neighborhood so you can pick
his up then you should find
something else to do and you might need
to find a new girlfriend what's
he saying don't pick up dog poop it's
9:30 you should have been
at work 3 hours ago ridiculous
don't do it and you'll be way better off
this clip is clearly taken out of
context maybe if watched it in full
context I'd be like yeah man don't do
fantasy football and never pick up your
girlfriend's dog poo but I don't
understand what he means or why that has
any correlation at all to why people are
broke it doesn't make any sense would
you rather have a 850 credit score make
4K a week for the rest your life or 2
million cash right now what that's a
no-brainer bro get that 850 credit score
make 4K a week for the rest of your life
with an 850 credit score which is not
even that good money is Limitless when
you know how to play this credit game yo
stop playing around yo get your credit
crit up that's one of the biggest things
I would tell my younger self give credit
up I mean maybe it's different in
England but in England 850 is fair to
good so the fact that he's so excited
about2 million or an £850 credit score
forget the 2 million give me that 850
credit score baby is a little bit
strange maybe the guy has got so many
cot judgments and maybe he's got bad
debt and and all kinds of stuff that the
idea of 850 is just worth more than 2
million but it doesn't make any sense
I'm the youngest billionaire in the
world right now what's your net worth
now I can explain this in a way I might
sound crazy I'm a billionaire let's
think about it does it billionaire have
a liquid billion dollars in his bank
account no okay so is he actually a
billionaire no
what what did you hear what he just said
I'm the youngest billionaire in the
world right now okay we've never heard
of you um I don't quite believe it but
may maybe it's true maybe it's true and
then he says well most billionaires do
they have a billion pounds in their Bank
no they don't so they actually a
billionaire no they're not yes they are
just because you haven't got a billion
pound in your bank doesn't mean you're
not a billion so him trying to discredit
them because they ain't got a billion in
their Bank suddenly makes him a
billionaire too let me tell you
something my friend here's how your net
worth is calculated it's all of your
assets and all of your wealth and the
money in your bank and your real estate
and your businesses minus your debts
everything you owe that is your net
figure so what the hell is this dude
talking about and he looks like a
cartoon character no one's heard of him
like liquid billionaire no I'm not a
liquid billionaire yet probably will be
mathematically soon but I'm a
billionaire because number one let's
just say I can make 500 to a mil a month
that's like 12 mil a year you do like a
money calculator since it's like a hedge
fund style thing let's say I could make
maybe what and maybe let's take a money
calculator since it's a hedge style fun
thing mate you are so slippery what are
you talking about and we're already in
the hundreds of millions and then other
businesses I'm a web3 wealth manager now
like I I own a hedge fund and manage
money for people if I went today and was
like I have this huge opportunity
everyone give me half a million doll
that can afford probably could raise
about $50 to $100 million right there
listen bro you know what i' be been more
impressed with okay clearly you're
making a bit of money I'd be more
impressed if you just said last year my
business turned over2 million and made a
profit of £500,000 okay good for you man
why say you're almost a trillionaire and
billionaire so that's it for Me Maybe I
didn't understand certain things maybe I
was over the top maybe the clips were
taken in different contexts and maybe
fill me in I don't know what are your
thoughts comment below I'd love to see
your opinions on these crazy ass
videos